for me I was at a point in my career
where I was perfectly happy on the
course I was but really just wanted to
take the next big step and for me coming
to the GSB being part of the MSX program
has been a way to really turbo boost
that development in in my career my
family is really important to me it's
the priority in my life and the MSX
program is one of the few programs out
there that is marketed not just to me as
a student but to my family and let the
experience that we have as family as a
whole it's provided a lot of
opportunities both for my wife and for
my children and more importantly it's
enabled us to have a great experience as
a family here on campus so the house was
a nice thing because we didn't have to
worry about that when we came here it
was fully provided everything was ready
for us we moved in we had actually
bought a housing package from a previous
MSX family just to make it comfortable
because we had the baby arriving so we
had new mattresses we had bedding we our
towels we had plates cups everything
ready for us
your garden just opens up onto this
beautiful courtyard there swings slides
and sand pits and it's just you're safe
it's been so stress free living here
with kids some of the best schools I
think in the state if not the country
and just knowing that our kids have that
opportunity as well as been been a great
thing so we wake up in a beautiful
campus
birds chirping and we normally get ready
to go to school everyone goes to school
we get everyone ready and Brittany
cycles with an Christine to school I
normally walk little Isabelle to Madeira
her preschool what do you do at school
oh we do school we do hard math and
we're we do reading and we have field
trips I go to the farm I like and I go
to the pumpkin pumpkin patch for me it's
been great this year being able to ride
with an Christine to school drop off
with the bike in the mornings and then
ride from there to school it's a great
time just to get exercise in at the same
time think about what's going to happen
in the day ahead
it's been just refreshing lifestyle
change
[Music]
so lindell's crammed in the continuing
studies this quarter and I felt like she
was taking more units than me and she's
just loved that she's released the
opportunity to just dive into that it's
been one of my transformations actually
this year and just different ways of
thinking and it can all be done
beautifully and you've got the courtyard
to send the children aren't you
we've just been very lucky with our year
our moms and dads have just really just
come together and we've been best of
friends it's been essential to have that
village on campus and we've picked up
kids helped each other drops off
groceries like when babies were born
I got meals delivered to us we've just
been there for each other it's been the
best year I would say this is one of the
best decisions you could make if you
decided to come as a family I think the
MSX program and the Stanford campus is
amazingly set up for families it's
something that's brought us closer
together as a family we've all grown
together as a family and I couldn't
imagine having done my degree any other
way
you
you